c'est dans cette forteresse que se joue
peut-être l'avenir de l'europe
le président français reçoit aujourd'hui
dans son lieu de villégiature son
homologue allemand angela merkel pour
faire un tour d'horizon des grands
sujets d'actualité internationaux selon
l'elysée premier dossier sur la table
qui concerne directement français
allemand la pandémie de kovy 19 le
nombre de contamination augmente dans
les deux pays par milliers ces derniers
jours avec des chiffres records plus
atteint depuis avril et mai dans les
colonnes de paris match ce jeudi
emmanuel macron s'exprime sur un
possible reconfirme ans nous avons des
stratégies très localisés comme ce qui
s'est passé en mayenne et allant jusqu'à
confinement cible et qu'on pourrait
instaurer si la situation l'imposait on
ne peut pas mettre le pays à l'arrêt
parce que les dommages collatéraux d'un
confinement sont considérables le risque
zéro n'existe jamais dans une société
le couple franco allemand continuera
d'affiner le plan européen de relance
économique de 750 milliards d'euros
conclu le 21 juillet par les 27 pays de
l'ue à eux toujours dans le domaine
économique en gala merkel et emmanuel
macron ouvriront aussi le dossier
breakes site
objectif trouver un terrain d'entente
avec le royaume uni dans des futurs
accords de libre-échange décisif
les deux chefs d'état attentif également
au volet libanais et à la reconstruction
d'un pays presque en ruine liban mali
biélorussie 3 pays qui demandent le
départ de leur gouvernement et l'appui
de la communauté internationale le
président français la chancelière
allemande sont attendus au tournant dans
ces zones stratégiques
leur position est pour leur commune avec
un seul mot d'ordre démocratie la france
et l'union européenne sont aux côtés de
la cedeao et de l'union africaine pour
trouver une issue à la crise malienne la
paix la stabilité la démocratie sont
notre priorité
les images des manifestants en
biélorussie des manifestations
pacifiques là bas nous ont beaucoup émus
ces derniers jours le courage de ceux
qui ont manifesté pacifiquement nous a
impressionnés et nous l'avons exprimée
ans
aujourd'hui au conseil européen et je
lui dis bien sûr aussi au nom du
gouvernement allemand nous sommes aux
côtés de ceux qui manifestent
pacifiquement monstre enfin peut-être le
dossier qui demandera le plus de
discussions la situation en méditerranée
orientale
ces derniers jours paris et a renforcé
sa présence militaire et s'est rangé du
côté de la grèce tout en dénonçant je
cite les décisions unilatérales turque
en matière d'exploration pétrolière
facteur de tension de son côté berlin se
montre moins virulent et directe envers
recep tayyip erdogan et apple avant tout
aux dialogues entre ankara et athènes